there are two Republican Senate races
for 2020 that we've been paying very
close attention to and in both of those
races Republican incumbents are in
bigger and bigger trouble every single
week and it is delightful views it's
there's so much bad news going around
right now um bad economic news bad
health news bad news about you you know
the laughable nature of American
leadership global the globe the
presidency seen as a global
laughingstock around the world this is
good news I'm talking about Arizona and
Maine I'll tell you about both of them
starting with Arizona in Arizona Martha
McSally is the junior senator
she has never been elected she was
appointed to serve out the remainder of
the late Republican Senator John
McCain's seat she's horrible I mean
truly horrible she now wants to be
elected for a full term she's running
against or running against her rather is
astronaut Mark Kelly Mark Kelly is the
brother of astronaut scott Kelly Scott's
been a guest on this program very
interesting conversation Mark Kelly is
also the husband of former Democratic
congresswoman Gabby Giffords who was
tragically shot years ago you may
remember the story and Mark Kelly would
be a tremendously good replacement for
Martha McSally and mcsalley isn't doing
well and I take great pleasure in that
in the latest poll mark Kelly is ahead
of martha mcsalley
by nine points this is huge it's hugely
important for the 20/20 balance of
Senate power which we've been talking
about because if Democrats are going to
take over control of the Senate in
November and it's a very uphill battle
winning this seat back is essentially a
necessity then we go to the state of
Maine in Maine we have our old friend
the perennial II disappointed Republican
senator Susan Collins she has a serious
opponent and that opponent is Democrat
Sarah Gideon
Susan Collins was first elected in 1996
she's had pretty easy re-election every
six years in 2002 in 2008 and in 2014
and she is sort of known for this is not
a great thing to be known for but
he's known for acting like she might
take a stand against her own party
against the Republican Party but then in
the end she always falls in line you
might remember that she was very
disappointed with Brett Kavanaugh
but then voted to confirm him to the
Supreme Court she was very disappointed
with Donald Trump's actions with Ukraine
but voted to acquit him in Trump's
impeachment trial months ago even though
it feels like that was years ago
so it is very much long overdue for
Susan Collins to go bye-bye
Sarah Gideon is trying the latest poll
is old now it's from March but it has
Gideon four points ahead very tight but
heading into her last reelection Susan
Collins had pretty high approval ratings
as high as 69% in 2014
Susan Collins latest approval rating is
37% okay Susan Collins was reelected in
2014 with a 69 percent approval rating
her approval rating is now 39% this is
very bad news for Susan Collins it's
very good news for Sarah Gideon but both
of these races races are going to be
fight so we can't take anything for
granted the reason I'm telling you this
is not so we can all sit back and say
hey we've got two of these that we're
going to take over why I'm telling you
this is to get you involved as you think
about phone banking if we remain stuck
at home for the foreseeable future these
are two great races where you could get
involved now I know some of you are
going to write to me and you're going to
say David you centrist chill neither
Sarah Gideon nor Mark Kelly are uber
progressive Bernie Sanders types that's
true but we're talking about removing
some really toxic Republicans here we
should all be fighting hard for that
neither Mark Kelly nor Sarah Gideon are
as left as Bernie Sanders but they are
orders of magnitude better than what we
have there right now and it's going to
be either mcsalley or Kelly right that's
it it's either going to be Susan Collins
or Sarah Gideon those are the choices
and defeating these two would be plus
two for Democrats in the Senate we're
going to lose Alabama right now former
senator and former attorney general Jeff
Sessions is running against doug jones
remember doug jones won against
in a special election against a serial
accused sex assault or predator I don't
know what word you want to apply to him
and now Jeff Sessions wants his seat
back Jeff Sessions is winning by 13 in
the latest polls we will almost
certainly lose that seat so we need
these two just to get plus one very
important consider phone banking there
will talk about other important races
upcoming make sure you're following me
on Twitter at D Pakman let me know how
the quarantine is going for you or if
you've unilaterally decided to end your
quarantine I would want to hear that as
well i'm deepak minh on twitter quick
break back after this privacy calm is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you $5.00 just for using their free
service at privacy comm slash Pakman
privacy's of service i've been using for
a while now i love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend just for signing up when you go
to privacy comm slash Pakman